como é que a substância pode ser
ajustada para todo o sul
há uns anos atrás eu era estudante de
direito e numa placa 2016 expressão
também uma noite em que dançava na
discoteca com um grupo de amigos e até
na altura ao passar na localidade de
amadeus nós filhos por meio da estrada
uma senhora nas costas uma criança ia
treinar para a estrada para tirar o
furação e havia também muitas pessoas
nas bermas das estradas a fazer sinal
para que parasse de dar nosso carro é
seu filho manter as urgências está
quarta passagem do estado de gravidade
da cintura da criança também foi saber o
que nós fizemos uma eternidade até que
ele é
está tudo bem mas não pense que isso
aconteceu aqui é coordenada pela frente
nas urgências pela hora da minha
carreira bem lá eu posso até dizer que
não havia quase ninguém meninas urgência
formações toda natureza
a criança foi atendida muito tempo
depois de ter chegado a um hospital
finalmente quando ela foi atendida
passado alguns minutos nós ficamos na
mesma enfermeira e arrancou para dentro
da silva e sada sairá a mais porque
ficar com os atacantes feira conta com
pepa 50 do universo
ela louvou ainda entrou eo show é perto
da marca depositou os prazos da mãe for
finalizada a criança de uma forma muito
fria muito cuida de faria já pertence
ainda alguns ficaram chocados com a
mulher e uma criança foi levada com vida
ao hospital chegou ao hospital que foi a
entrada na oi não conseguimos acreditar
que mesmo aceitar
ainda tentava adquirir a tentamos fazê
lo turquia não é gostoso
presenciamos a conclusão mas ainda assim
ela mas também publicados em razão da
própria pessoa muito ensinada e até
achar uma pergunta não consegue mesmo
tempo a culpada mas essa criança duas
filhas ao rei vontade de nossa sociedade
fundada mesmo cuidado desfechos que o
mesmo estava convidado já fez a 0 sobre
o coxa
há muitas
nossa sociedade nós queremos a serem
toda hora em todo o mago dos casos a
cada um de vocês aqui dentro também cria
um exemplo para nós e para todos é o do
estádio de al é um fim em alguns países
não sabia lidar na minha vida eu mais do
que procurar responder à pergunta como
ela é feita com a iluminada
a descrição de um pai e agente social
econômica e política
quantas vezes nós não temos no nosso dia
a dia
acho um absurdo isso já terminados
concurso determinadas a oportunidade
apenas porque não têm política tem que
conhecer econômica não tem qualquer
destaque social para todos os trechos
sul e isso é um aspecto comprometer
seriamente a realização da justiça que é
por aí que nós devemos caminhar no
atacado
nós temos uma sociedade que neste
momento passa por uma crise muito
profunda
a liga da justiça isso nem toda a gente
fala toda a gente concorda toda a gente
sabe que nós temos e há elementos que
mostram e à impunidade predomina a
ilegalidade atacou o retorno lado nós
guardá los
assistimos todos os dias
há outros suspeitos mas não diz respeito
à consciência pela bem nós não
conseguimos é por que fazer com que as
pessoas são diferentes umas das outras e
5 respectivamente
quem é cada um deixa os direitos de um
deve viver de teatro por exemplo os
mesmos princípios e precisa direitinho e
assim sustentar cada um
por isso nós temos há muito que fazer
para se manter essa situação e como é
que nós podemos fazer como é que a
justiça pode ser justo trabalhadores
nós devemos começar desde logo a vale a
investir muito na consciencialização das
pessoas e educar os cidadãos para o show
para conhecer os direitos que lhes
assistem pra que eu saiba efetivamente
que têm esses direitos e como é que olha
e agir enquanto força que eles têm para
me atingir várias frentes são pilares
sensibilizar as pessoas pra eu acho se
tornarem mais tona si próprio acho que
não sentirei dancei fechar quatro do céu
em alguma discriminação pode sofrer
alguma justiça pelos rivais menta
sensibilizar as pessoas e tu falas a
tornarem adultas em lance parecido neste
domingo
é preciso também nós termos algum algum
cuidado ou dedicar-nos mais que mais
gosta de nós todos todos e cada um de
nós é da sociedade nós temos que
contribuir de alguma forma para a
promoção da justiça agir para que
efetivamente haja mais justiça nacional
falar às vezes sobre o tema é
sensibilizar e estimular as pessoas e
sobretudo aquelas pessoas que querem
menos oportunidade de aprofundar sua
vida ela suas metas ligadas a saber
efetivamente existe justiça do paraná a
acreditar na justiça contra as pedras
devido respeito à nossa sociedade é uma
descrença total da justiça hoje em dia
suas palavras como o cidadão hoje vemos
que na europa acredita minimamente à
justiça
ela demonstra facilmente ter violado o
direito eu nem cheguei a pensar que se
dá ao trabalho de procurar a justiça
porque porque pensa logo que o fracasso
não vai acontecer nada aqui quando o teu
aquela injustiça a que lhe causou ao
cuidado que a trilogia direito
portanto isso achei muito em ações de
promoção da justiça em ações de
sensibilização e formação das pessoas
também é preciso que a sociedade como um
pouco por cada um de nós esteja que agia
branca qualquer
o unirei que seja nosso diretamente seja
de outra pessoa
eu até prefiro dizer que nós podemos
estar sempre dispostos a agir quando há
alguma situação de rua são diferentes
daqueles que será um luxo mais tipo de
gente na cidade e não ficamos à espera
ou pensar aí eu vou fazer nada
ontem não tem nada a ver com isso não
vai pesar na minha festa de 90 da minha
família na ferrari
hoje também podemos ser nós que nós
temos que ver que realmente é pré
dispostos a agir e até atingir
efetivamente haja justiça para todos um
outro aspecto a considerar foi investir
para o nosso objetivo para esse grande
objetivo tenha a ver com ele se gência é
preciso haver também maior exigência
exigência tem passar à sociedade
novamente a mesma maior exigência e
dependência da dedicação bem bem o de
zelo por parte daqueles que salva as
dores da justiça e quem são as cores da
justiça eu vou falar nos jogos da
polícia
estou a falar aos funcionários judiciais
geral do ministério público estadual dos
advogados
estou a falar com os magistrados
portanto é preciso que esses fatores diz
a sinval mais acionados sinto ouvir a
sociedade está colheu de filmes técnico
efetivamente mais seu desempenho mais
dedicação eo a onu avisa haver maior
exigência ainda aqui na verdade o mesmo
as pessoas mais que a exigência que é
preciso haver mais exigência de
qualidade mas exigência
se ficar acima daquilo que o produto do
trabalho desses 500 e é preciso acima de
tudo a ver é maior exigência do
resultado não vai ter que essas pessoas
continuem a fazer o seu trabalho
ali terno sem que se veja e um trabalho
neutros produzir alguma coisa tem de
sentir e eu bebi uma meta assim a
chuteira euros bem qualquer coisa que
não produzam algum resultado
outro aspecto também pesará cusack de
forma determinada
olha para esse objetivo de fazer uma
justiça um pouco mais justa para todos é
apostará também da responsabilização boa
brincadeira com ela a responsabilização
efetiva das pessoas e são os fatores da
justiça que devem aplicar a justiça e
também daqueles que cometem as
injustiças porque é por isso que eu
saiba que seu aliarem a mal da justiça
para agradecer a sobre eles que estavam
estacionados que isso não tenha
acontecido nada
também faz parte do deck ou jurídica
trazer este ano
esta ferramenta para mim
a sociedade civil tem o papel de
determinado para ser alcançado por
justiça pra todo mundo que eu já falei
aqui tranquilo mas sobretudo porque a
ser assim mil deve à china é para
promover ações da organização justiça
deve reagir para das justiças que sejam
verificadas a sociedade civil segue
também o papel deve ter um papel de
fiscalizadora para garantir tereos que
estão encarregues de administrar a
justiça e mesmo aqueles que pretendem
com as injustiças será o da vida venta
portanto nós todos todos na sua nova iê
cada um na sua esfera pessoal
temos um papel importante a desempenhar
não pelos modelos com medo de
represálias do governo bocker saum
censura quando eu nunca teria chegaremos
a um ponto mais próximo da justiça
operadores reagiram
a gente tem medo de enfrentar com essa
convenção
esse princípio tem orientado ao longo da
áfrica vai toda a minha vida por isso
quando for escolher o curso é isso leva
todos os dias sem injeção a juntar se a
quaisquer movimentos associativos que
visa promover a justiça vai agir com as
pesquisas que eu tenha conhecimento e
sobretudo e vivi na minha opinião sempre
tem alguns condenados em minha opinião
sem medo sem receio é um desafio que eu
também gostaria de deixar aqui hoje para
cada um você já participar desse evento
é de 1 em casa de um primo fora faça
algo democracias a sociedade para dizer
que pediram apenas conseguiu alcançar
eles bem com isso consiga ter um pouco
menos de justiça para todos